last year when i started my own management i was
very busy with how
things work and
how things work before that i
didn't even have a clue how banks
work more or less because
i knew okay i have a
bank account and so on  the bank and I
have a bank account in the bank I somehow have to transfer
something once a month
and
that's it I had I had no idea
how what works great tennis
is about to come or to put it another
way Alex Zverev is one of the few
global sports stars  we in
Germany recently had some sports
that you had in the podcast Toni Kroos
Marco Reus Dennis Schröder also fits
because in the end everything is almost
forced Influenza digital
Entrepreneurs in the case of tennis players
even models and the tennis court
is kind of the catwalk or
since the the catwalk by the way smaller fun
fact im  In the background you can see
people walking around from time to time, these are the
colleagues from RTL who are currently shooting a documentary
about the life of Alex Werner,
who was there when
we took the picture and were of course honored for us,
but they are now in the picture, don't
let them irritate them  nothing
they run through picture so if you are still
very very much content of conversation
his investments his career his
view of the tennis industry everything
now with Alex
welcome Alex 12 hello good day
tell me is somehow Hamburg is awesome for
you Hamburg is  the
city where i where i grew up where
i was born where i grew
up so i went to school here
i lived all my life
so it's already the city where
home is for me so it's
always special to come back  always
playing here in a special way and
somehow just being there sometimes,
ne noticed that in the let  The last
few days special things have
happened in Hamburg in relation to the
honorary citizens of our city here
I am I actually only
arrived yesterday a deceased Uwe Seeler
was but that was not a few
days ago happened a few weeks
ago Udo Lindenberg is  As an honorary
citizen, I also heard you right away,
my Uwe Seeler
I absolutely love it, I think the biggest
sports legend we have in Hamburg, no
, you really have to
say that, it’s no longer there,
somehow, we could have, because the
new ones, and then think  you think okay
so who are what are there for world stars
and suddenly you think okay purely
theoretically somehow but I'm still
in I'm still in my church I'm
still in the middle of it so
I think it's something else when you
're already done  my then come
look back and say oh I
achieved that I didn't achieve that and
so on and so forth is with me
still in the thick of it that's why i do
n't see myself as a legend i don't see myself
as a
great superstar or anything else so
you're in the city's golden book that
's me
after the olympic victory was that after
the olympic last year and what
started here  in the UAC so the club in
the north of Hamburg actually known
one of the best Germans about one
yes hockey was always the number one
sport so I used to play
hockey my youth team
really became German
champions so we weren’t exactly yes
that’s yes  much older than me he's
more my brother's age I
think he's even older than my
brother but he used to
train tennis with my father
funnily enough so I know him very
well we know say yes we rent out the whole
family very very well too
my timer is fine I was practically
born there on the tennis courts
there but okay you're open again
I heard that too I was 12 I quit hockey and soccer when I was 12
I actually played three
sports when I was 12 and
then I just didn't have the time
anymore because I really wanted to
focus on one sport, tennis
and yes then  I just had the
others I didn't I didn't
go to training
any more at some point I just
didn't have the time for the league games anymore
and so on that's why I
cleaned up a bit, of course it's
okay in tennis that could open up  In any case,
getting really good
is never clear, so I was
talented, I was good, but I do
n't know one of the best in Europe, I was
maybe number 5, number 6 in
Europe, or
at 12 with at 13 14 I was
number 6 too  7 in Europe in my year
no, but I was never number one, I was
never number two, that
somehow developed a bit
later and I'm glad  With the
help of my parents, I also practice half of
my brother’s,
later
I just saw how
profile life works and that
helped me a lot I
mean Hamburg helped you a bit
because you were 17 I saw it
is there  got the wildcard to play here at the
tournament in Hamburg and that
was the ticket, so to speak, not
to have to play the very small tournaments
or to get in big relatively quickly
that was a bit of the beginning,
so I’m from 300 in the world
130 gone in the world
within a week I played
semi-finals here in Hamburg of course
at 17 with 17 through with a
voting card here in this stadium that
was something special ne so
suddenly the whole city of Hamburg really had
a bit of tennis  interested for the
first time in years and that
was nice to see and for
17 year olds it was all a bit like that
wow i'm playing for the first time in a big
stadium i'm playing in front of a
huge audience that was
really special i would say what helped
me a lot like i said that my brother was a
professional before me and that i've experienced the whole
world of tournaments that
i
I've already experienced the whole professional world and
knew exactly how what works, I think
that at a young age, above all, it helped me a
lot how far
along is a business for you in tennis at the end of the day,
also that you make decisions based on business decisions
I play tournaments because there is
somehow good prize money or there is a
lot of TV coverage or
somehow because of this I think I think
like any other sport,
tennis is just a bit ne,
so you only ever see what happens on the
tennis court in sporting
life  and also in business life one
sees only really okay one
plays human being for two hours and then
d  enken everyone you go home
had a beer in the evening and then go to
sleep somehow that doesn't happen like
that because the preparation and everything that
happens on the side happens
months in advance, so you sometimes decide six months in advance
which tournament you're going to  Which
tournament you don't go to, that's
always negotiations, that's always
talks, different tournaments,
with different sponsors, with
different companies, where what happens,
that's why
sporting decisions and business
decisions, as we like to say, it's the way it
is with most tennis
players  a manager and he
decides everything for you so you're
always just told okay you go there
that day you do you have these
periods you have this interview and
that's it for me it wasn't different
it used to be the same for me but I
have  then at some point
early last year I made the decision that I
said I would  I took everything my
own hand and announced my own
management
opened it up
with my brother and with Serge Bubka
and just
to take matters into my own hands because I never wanted to
just be a passenger in my
own career and  that
just happens with management where you
don't really have any influence,
that's why it's already the case
that I have my career completely in
my own hands with the help
of others, of course, and how do you
think about it, so now
we can decide for ourselves
first of all we said
what a huge difference was that
Germany is very very important to me
is that I want to feel like one with the German
people
I
want the German people to see the
German  Audience also gets to
know me better that was a huge changeover
to the management before that d  ass I had
I was always seen as a world star
the German doesn't really matter
so more or less what bothered me a
bit but as
I said I had
no say what that was concerned
I always just did what I was
told what  also okay was at a young age
then the second thing I changed a lot was
I sign with companies
now not just because of the money
that was also clear in the past if a manager is
behind it if you if a big
company is behind it it used
to
be like that most of the time  Money pays then
I get the most percentage of it or
not I but my manager gets
the most percentage of it makes
the most sense for him now since
last year I've been the type of guy who
also wants to help build up companies I have
two of my own companies with me  Eisbein and and
improva
once it's a virtual
training system that your
brain controls norathletics
training  virtual reality
glasses
and the second company is Eisbein
that sounds very German is also a
German company and
we thought okay
what do the athletes always do after and
after training what do many do for
recovery Per Mertesacker has this one
with these  well-known sentence with the
squirrel said I'm going
to the ice bin for two days now and then
we'll talk about it later I
thought okay but there has to
be a better way, no, and then
we created recovery pants where
you can take the temperature of the pants  with
water also with liquid that does
n't touch your skin that's the
big difference because with the ice bucket there
is still a risk that you
can catch a cold that you can
actually get an infection and
so on and so forth and
it's the same with pants  you can adjust the pants
from 20 to 3 degrees
exactly and then you can set
how cold you want them to
be  adjust how the water
flows there you can adjust how long
you want to stay in there
and so on and I think that’s
easy there is progress from
this ice barrel
and people who
have had an operation, for example, can do that too  have now had a
hip operation or who have now had a
knee operation in the hospital
you can't tell them okay
you'll sit in the
ice zone for half an hour it's not so easy to
wear pants you can still check
the recovery for
carry out for these people and what
another company founded I saw part
Break Ventures so a vehicle exactly
that's with my brother and another
business partner that's easy
for us we want to be
clear we all want to earn money that
's what we need  don't talk about it
every man wants to make money and
want to make money with another
way we want to investier  s and work with
companies that are
also changing the world, that means
nature conservation, that is, any new
ecosystems, any
forge progress that is simply
making the world not just now, for example,
okay, we are now investing in oil and gas,
so we earn so and so
many percentages every year if  we
want to invest in companies
that we really have the
feeling that makes the world a better place,
okay then, how close are you to it, so
I mean, in addition to your sports career, you are now,
so to speak, a really active investor or
angel or whatever you want to call it  yes
but i also enjoy it i
said that too i was
just a passenger in my career since i was 15 as i
said before i never really noticed i
never really understood what was being
done to me no until i  hold it
all in my own again and
it's really great fun for me to do it
that way  of course I
don't have to help people anymore of
course I have other partners of course
I always have management
people who just help me because
during the day I also have to
play tennis so I train eight hours
a day I can't do 10
hours a day now  Some day some
business plans
[music] are
busy, so in the end it's
somehow you have to learn it
like tennis, so you look at them what it's
about what are the costs and the result
how do companies grow with such for
that we have in the ventures  the
third person the
masters creed has in business too
and i have now also in the
last four months three and a half months
since the injury i have
been dealing with it i have also done a
lot and last year also last
year when i in my own
Management have kept me busy with
how things
work at all  s is running
before that I had no idea how
banks work so more or
less I knew okay I have
a bank account and such and such a bank and
I have a banker in the bank I somehow have to
transfer something once a month to something
and  that
was it i had i had no idea
how what works you were
inspired by other athletes i
mean there is lebron james so that
the curry that in the big room i
was inspired like i said i
had huge problems with my
management earlier no  So I was in
court
for years with management
, I also won the court
and I had the feeling
that I
wasn't being treated fairly towards me and that
motivated me more I really wanted to
understand how things work because in the
end  the day i had no idea
i was
just a tennis player that was there
more more there was more of
alexander zvere there was  not and now
I understand how things
work more but let's say
tennis is such a big
benchmark is somehow Roger Federer
and then they've been doing it for
a long time it's kind of crass
investments this shoe brand makes on here
and stuff like that  will probably have
observed
with him it's still like that, so if he
makes an investment I think I
always get it for a quarter of the price more
or less simply because of course
the company on it has
grown incredibly since Roger Feder is part
owner of the company but  I also
think that she rose because of Roger
Federer no, well, I think that
makes a huge difference whether
her Federer goes with Nike shoes
or gloves on the tennis court
just like when he went from Nike to
eniglo that was a  huge
boom not only in the tennis world
but in general in the world of
sportmark and sport brands because of it
Everything Roger Federer touches
will always have a huge effect,
so I think it's always so clear that
he earns a lot of money so
he makes the right
decisions, I would say, but he also makes
them at a really good
price, you have to  Don't forget
that in tennis there is still such a
crass hierarchy where technically
you are number two in the world and you are the
winner so you are
already crass successful
always look okay Roger Federer Nadal
Djokovic that's still how it
felt, no  I mean if someone
wins 22 or 20 outright
that's
so I'm still a long way from
that it's just like
that those are the best tennis players
maybe the best athletes of all time
so you mustn't forget that
's a that's normal
yes you want to win that  I
've already done it a few times,
I'll say something like that against the
players, I always have good matches, I won't say
that  I always win but
I always have good matches but that
's already if you talk about the
business world with Michael
Jordan if everyone wants to have something to
do with Roger Federn everyone also wants
to have something to do that's
just that  also from a sporting point of view
that's just really
another level there are a few
athletes you hang out with who
don't play tennis at all, for example
like that Jimmy Butler
[music]
NBA star Miami Heat noticed how come
he loves tennis me  love basketball
we first got to know each other and
wimbilden chamber for one of my
matches and that's how it started somehow
then I was
then he was in a lot of tournaments but
Panini is up at the labercup with me
and so on and so on then I was
with  him there if you always in
Miami for a week we
trained together sometimes that
just arises you know the this contact
between sports  he just stands up often
because the interest in other
sports is just because i love
basketball i love the miami heat
miami every my my team
mavericks although the joke thought no
funnier i know him too um and
i love him is one of the greatest
guys in the world but when he won everything
against Miami I was already
disappointed
don't just say
but that just happens no this contact
between athletes is always in
basketball a lot happened in the last year
because they used to be so super
analytical  did you
always try to score the points somehow close to your head
two points then
you understood okay throwing
makes more sense and the odds also
go up when they go up so much like that sports
analytics
do you look at tennis like that or are
you wondering okay what can  I
somehow analytical key data KPIs how
can I try
to understand tennis again because it's in
Basketball yes so obviously has changed the whole
game I think
team athletes in general are more
statistical sports I think because
you can make me a tennis is
a
one on one sport it's a
sport where you have to listen to your instincts
more I think it's also
difficult because you  you have to play
different opponents you actually
just have to play differently ne so if
you play it against Rafa totally
or if you play against
Joker again there are two different
types ne there are two different
types of play and you also have
to adapt and the other thing is  yes, even the
best players in the world
always adapt, so do you look at it
quantitatively or do you
do it, I'll do it, I'll do it, I'll look at the statistics, I'll do it, but I think it brings more in
team athletes  more in
football that brings more in
basketball I think that's okay d  it's
kind of called the idea of ​​saying how
many days of break do you need between
tournaments somehow everything
I understand before or oh yes but
that that partly that partly
we can't even decide because we
have we have a game
plan  we just have to play, we had to
play or want to play a lot of the four
, we also have the new
Masters here,
they are seen as compulsory tournaments by the ATP,
then we
have to play 2,500 or 3,500 a year, I think, that
means that’s it  full you play 18 19
tournaments
where you don't have a choice to
play doubles so I somehow
noticed Roger Federer
deliberately plays little doubles because he
just doesn't play that game but I
also don't play doubles only doubles if
it's my brother or if
my best friend Marcel Lamello
somehow asks me to play twice with him
because he couldn't find any other
partners  or something like that or
I'm playing now I'm playing
doubles now if I haven't played a tournament for a long time
and then
want to get in somehow as the first match I'll do that
but I'm
not saying that I've also
played doubles in Minecraft at a Grand Slam  and
that was when I was 19 that's
not so twice it's really not
okay well but in general I thought it
would be obvious tennis to be even more
analytical in baseball is
also really crazy she started
with this moneyball where you look closely
now there's  also all kinds of
measurements so but each one
you mentioned is a
team sport
yes but still you have percentages you
have the baton you have
different positions tennis up
to 1 against 1 in tennis you have the
opponent and I myself and if you  have a
bad day you have a
bad day you won't
win so no matter how much w  How much how
much analytical things
have you looked at somehow you wo
n't win on the court if you have a
bad place somehow
Petkovic just said that
are psychopath games in the end tennis
I think psychologically it's a
sister sport in the world that
is  that's true i think with
golf it's also
extremely difficult because you ca
n't rely on anyone either you're completely
alone you don't have a coach on the
course you don't have any teammates on the
course you're completely alone in the
greatest moments you know that you are
you have the work behind you but if you
somehow have match point in a final
or in an Olympic final
you still tremble, so I
can guarantee you that, I was there for
that reason, so mental trainers, for you, the
relatively large element of the training is
really too psychological, too
prepare
yes also I even so I do
n't have mental trainer but  ern
a sports psychologist who
I work with to just stay with myself in the most important
moments
, I already have that,
but everyone has their own way, no,
Novak, for example, is extremely
connected to nature, no, he tries to use
the energy of
trees and plants
also works with a
person who is supposed to give him energy somehow
Rafa is more relaxed there Rafa is he
in his environment then he plays a
board game he is very
great the station
always has to stand the shoes up straight we have to stand up for
the bottles
and so on that's what's
right for him is fairer
I think rather the opposite making mistakes
tries to do it on purpose that
he doesn't have any quirks so really
do everything completely differently fear the
day before that's
why you always have to for yourself
find the right one yourself you can't say
okay it works that's why
I'm doing the same thing now
Ten  nisplatz is actually
a bit like a catwalk, like a
stage, yes, I mean, you are
right, especially lately, it
has become like this absolutely always,
it is almost
impossible to present clothes like this better in almost any sport, and in
basketball, they will too  done that way but of
course everyone has
to wear their uniform somehow and it's a
bit about the shoes but in
tennis we can really do a lot is
too present during the game or
think about it I
think adidas is the right thing to do  no we
have we have meetings twice a year twice a
year and go through the
collection and say
i like that i don't like that i brought back
a little yes that love
lets you know what
kinda got lost after
the nadal up  once i
played with it a couple of months suddenly
nike comes with dear so that was
so wow okay for me too so especially my
s  achen was very well received that was that was
sold very well by Adidas we also went through a
lot no so we
had this basketball look in
Australia then I still loved
playing it months later and suddenly
at Roller players you play
Nike all love  actually
thought
interesting
so you have an impact and I
think at the end of the day when your stuff is
sold and if adidas
makes a good living from it you can see that it works
and suddenly Nike starts to
imitate it suddenly other companies receive it
so you think left-wing  you're already
thinking more about it what kind of clothes do I wear what kind of socks do I
wear Slee
2 there are things I like there
are things I don't like I
have I have also I think it was in
2017 at the US Open I had  try
this Björn Borg look with the long
long socks with this
polo shirt, although Björn Borg has
never played an adidas  ern was
always a lot, adidas did this Björn
Borg look together with Pharrell Williams back
then,
yes,
there are really freaky things,
there are crazy things, but
there are also things that I really
like, I love that, I love
the onion  -Look, I love having the
feeling that you have freedom, that you
somehow still hate this young savage a
little bit and that in tennis is not
more typical, so in the past
you always had to play everything in white,
then you had to play a polo shirt  and
now you have the feeling you
can do anything and why do
n't you try things out tennis is also a
paradise so probably for these
reasons for luxury watches but I find it
really interesting what's going on there so I
mean you already have different ones
Partnerships even existed
I think I had my freshly
I was together for three years yes
I also had my own  Clock at
Richard's me what you did that
cost 200,000 or something like that I think it
even cost more I have I
have I have partly Bavarian
flour I played with a clock
that cost 800,000 €
no because if something happened it wasn't
it's like that again the watch you know
but
you also think about it somehow when it
's a crazy world where
you end up so
now I'm with Rolex and I
'm extremely happy because Rolex
is a watch that has a lot of history
has internet that has a lot of
history in peace anyway
but also in tennis and so I
thought to myself now it belongs to the Rolex
family it is more than a
friendly partnership for me erm it
’s a family that’s
something where  where you can say okay
Rolex will keep the partnership even if
your career is over, so
you can see how many Explorers
still have how many really s  Nice
partnerships that I have too and
the one with my foundation, they
immediately said we'd help
out too, no, that's fine,
or please hit that, that's more than
a partnership, that's not, that's
not just a donor and says
okay here  Please wear your watch and
that's it. It's a partnership
where yes, where there's a lot of work involved,
but do you also observe what
other tennis players
enter into partnerships who is being promoted and
who is behind them? That's
one of those things  you know each other like that
yes I mean at the end of the day you see
it hiding at the end of the day
I think it is also
Serge and Micha's job to know a bit
more what is
where is the money where which
partnerships  are doing and so
on and so forth but you can
also see which athletes or which
tennis players
are after the money you can look at the partnerships
see extremely well and you can also see
okay who really wants to build up a brand,
let's say no, and
maybe it will still be there after tennis and
I definitely think that's the way to go, so that's definitely the way
for me  the way because
if there is the one who has the tennis court
and the tennis sport I can play
until I'm 35 36 37 now they
all play until they're 40 but I do
n't know if I can do it you never have
a guarantee
but what  after
that you still have your whole life ahead of you
no and yes but you still
want to stand for something no you still want to stand
for something in the world and I
want to be more than just the
tennis player you know now
follows you like that  also the career Boris
Becker, for example, talking about it
after the career that didn't work out
so well is that
close to you it's a role for you you know each
other well and I know you  great and
for me it's also a great guy I I
can't and will never
say a bad word about Boris, of course,
many decisions were
wrong, I'll say it myself
, maybe the people and
business partners he dealt with were wrong
, but  boah is as a
person is a 1A guy and that's the way it is
and in Germany it's always like that
we love it
well that's how the well-known people like
you love to put down the heroes a
bit
and that's clear  that
has often happened to Boris now
, of
course, to show what you are
doing. TV shows, you
somehow still go out and are now really trying to
build up a recognizable brand yourself, even at the
risk that one could then get more of
something like yours
now the good news i'll get it
too so i'll always
get it i've
gotten it on my cellphone often enough already  he
at the end of the day the media
nowadays I've often said that
the story is more important than the
truth sometimes how many sheets are
sold how often the story is
clicked on is sometimes much more
important than what the truth
actually is I have now
Funnily enough, I saw the Louis
figure film on Netflix,
it was amazing, it started back
then, so how much was being
lied about how much was really
one kidding the other
these marker markers or somehow something
Spanish exactly what she
wrote there  and they also say
publicly that was a lie it was
fictitious yes cool so they say
yes it is from Real to Barca or something like that
from Barca to Real they
don't say that either they say yes that was fictitious
but that was  stop the story
and everyone in Spain has read that then
I also think to myself
how often that has happened to me how often that has happened
to others  It
happened to other athletes that I, well, that's amazing
how important it is for you to tell your own story,
so to speak, via social media but insta
or something like that
,
but
sometimes you're
not allowed to tell your own story at all, no, because
I've said that often to you  are you
not allowed to
say what I mean publicly or be public
as you want to be if you are
not allowed to you always have to say everything correctly
you always have to present yourself correctly
or if
I'm not the type at all I'm not the type to always
do everything  says as it is prescribed for him
I'm not the type who
always presents himself as it is
prescribed for him I I want to be
me and you're not allowed to do that these days
because on social media everyone has
an opinion except actually
you yourself that you  you don't actually have
an opinion at all, but you give it a
lot of thought so it's
an instrument for you, so to speak  where you can
obviously also build with the market
I my episodes of the almost 2
million people do you think
about it strategically
yes
but instagram is more
for the fans I think it's more for the fans
it's more for the people who
maybe  Yes, I want to get a little bit of life out of
it. I know that Instagram and social
media in general is
extremely important for films. It is extremely important for
business partners. But
for me, the real world is really
like that  I think it's
more important okay that means how you are
now not so active that you
think about what I'm posting now and look
at how many people have liked it what kind
of comments did others make
in the comments and how many
people liked it  and what
kind of comment there was I
don't even look at it because at the end of the
day I think I would get
depressed  h so um well but of course you
want the fans especially I
think more in the fans if it's
between me I would like to give an
insight into my life and show
how and what I do and for the people they
just don't like that  noticed that they can
at least see
what my life looks like through Instagram I always thought
maybe the big collaboration
with a wig
would come I got to know him
also
very very funny guy
people witnessed some world champions but that’s
true then Nico Rosberg in 2014
maybe I’ll have a look  shut
yourself out do you hear that you have a great guy
is super funny too and for whom he
commented and you can
do a lot with him no that's true
you should think about tennis yourself you give
a lot of thought to the sport how
to develop it further  should
there be a big development in golf right now
that, so to speak, all of
a sudden, an association of its own is splitting off
or is that you sa  Gst just no that
the framework is given to me I'm
the player or are you already there so
that there
's a lot of talk about it
now this whole PTA designed by Novak
or a video is always called
I don't even know about it you
talk a lot and the  I have to
develop tennis further that's very clear so
we are we are we earn very well
in our sport of it there is
n't anything wrong but only the
top 10 then the top 30 I I ca
n't I can't complain that's
that is  wrong to complain at all
so no, but in terms of the
percentage of what the tournaments
earn from what the event
earns and so on and so forth,
tennis is already one of the
sports that there are in the world,
I believe, merits little, no, I believe in it  Unlike basketball
football
NFL golf and stuff like that we're really
percentage percentage the deepest
example so I think Rafael Nadal
Kur  Earnings from playing tennis are
around 140 million. There are some quarterbacks in the NFL who both don't have 250 million. Jimmy to jimmy has become one of my best
friends now, but he's earned
180 million in four years, so
I have no chance of 80
million  to earn in four years,
but that's also I ca
n't complain, that's
really, that's complaining at the
high level, but in terms of percentages,
we're still very low,
so in Grand Slams,
I really think I earn less than eight percent  it
's not a problem that mainly only
the top players I think it would
be much better for the sport if he say
the first two but for that
we have to make more money generally
no so you can't say okay if
you're in the first  you lose a round you earn
30,000 if you win it me
earn 50,000 that's
not possible either ne so you have to you
have to j  There can be an increase in
terms of prize money because otherwise it
doesn't make any sense,
so the
percentage and everything has to be higher
because at the end of the day, as I said,
the top 30 feel extremely
good we feel extremely good but
afterwards  It doesn't matter much if you
if you in the game yourself so if you
somehow tell yourself the rules of the
game in basketball NBA there
are new rules every year or in football there are
also new rules but contact sports are
okay but even so things are changing
a bit  kind of how
long you shot clock times
but we have that too we
introduced a shotglock we introduced
toilet break regulations and
so on you can't you
can't change the rules okay you
just play it with
a rash and the  Lines are
shortened and so on and so forth that
the tennis game has to remain so
no that you two knockouts  you have
to play up to 6 and that
you have to win two sets that has to remain the
small rules they can change they
change too we have a
shotglock we might have a break rule
we have I
don’t even know from that  from the
head but things are already changing
at Grand Slams are now being played in the fifth
set during hybridge ne and
these are changes that are
big Davis Club is now only playing Best
of 3 like we
no longer play these home and
away games but  we play a lot in
one place we now have four
teams here in Hamburg that
's a change and
tennis is changing,
but the general rules and
how tennis is played in
general has to stay what was
actually the case  your career
so far the craziest moments apart
from tennis that were made possible
because you play tennis like that  ler I've
seen there are pictures where you
hang out with Jay Zero and something like that the
moments says okay that was blatant
aren't even moments but
acquaintances who are just the cash
register as you said yourself Jay Z
who suddenly am  I was invited to his
at this 44 club and New York to his
birthday goal from his club
then suddenly hanging out with him no
even that okay a little bit real
no um then yes
friendships like with Jimmy
friendships like with other
soccer players and stuff  go on
so it's better for you yes Jimmy
I think from the athletes is very
extremely close for me is still a very
close person Roger I have to
say honestly has helped me a lot
in my career
football player TV all the Bayern
boys Thomas  Müller I have
a bit of contact with but then
mainly the as monoko guys ne Kevin
Volland uh Nübel
hangs around together that we have  n
we have one, we have WhatsApp,
a group called the Monaco
regulars’ table, the regulars’ table are all the footballers who play
in the car, all Formula 1 drivers
, that is, Hülkenberg, a couple of other
guys have an office, we have
Robert Geiss, we still have that in the group
I have to say is one of the
funniest to introduce, yes, he
is very funny in that regard, the one
who invited us all to the
Oktoberfest wrote to me
yesterday whether I
would like to go to the Oktoberfest with him on Saturday, but
somehow I wrote back I'm
already in  Hamburg, unfortunately, but thanks for
the invitation,
yes, that's why we already have your
funny group,
okay,
tell me you recently made the topic of
diabetes
public  to do why
has it been so difficult for so long
because I felt uncomfortable with it for a very long time
ha  be
I was just I got it when
I was three I was just at school and
as a teenager it was always different
I always had to have injections I didn't have
measuring devices I had to
use and so on and
so forth and I think I felt very uncomfortable with it
Me too, because
when I switched to high school, I switched
to our sports high school here in Hamburg
, where I was
the only tennis player and all the
other footballers were,
some of my equipment was broken
and so on and that's
why I just made myself  felt very uncomfortable
with the whole thing and uh, since
I said to myself at some point so
plus there is also I was
always told that I will never
make it with diabetes from various
first from various specialists who
somehow said yes competitive
athletes with the picture is yes
impossible like that and
at some point I thought to
myself okay I'm number two in the world I'm
Ol  ympia winner
i can actually help others in that regard i can
encourage others
i can
just be a bit of the messenger when
it comes to the topic and then
i thought to myself ok i feel
good now i am 25 years old and i
want other children  above all
helping other parents and showing
that everything is possible with her
and that's why I made it public
because with that I didn't get it on
my cell phone I bought it on my
black diabetes device thought
at the time
I thought to myself okay awesome that
you still somehow didn't want to say it at the time
like I said I felt uncomfortable
really always struggled with it for years
and
yes, then at some point for
a while what you said about him management
there, it just always became a bit
business-like  see and so on and
since I've
always felt good diabetes business strategy
no if then I really want to do it
to help people
and that's just a part of
really being the messenger and so
on  other part is really if a
child gets diabetes in Africa or in different
Asia Asian countries it dies
within a few days
maybe weeks because it
just doesn't have the supplies it does
n't have insulin it doesn't have any measuring devices
it's just not let me put it
that way  Stocks up above to stay alive and
I really want everyone in
the whole world to have the chance to have
diabetes in their
entirety and that's unfortunately not the case at the moment, unfortunately we
're still living in 2022 no
and I'd like
one then  Being help,
the foundation is somehow you know,
like the workers, how they are set up,
so you push money in and then
which project  e are required there well
at the end of the day it is
still at the beginning we have
understood different event horses
different events I of course put
money into it myself and
so on of
course I still collect a lot
we will be doing many events until the end of the
year,
our first goal is, for example
, to send the necessary supplies to the Ukraine,
because at the
moment it’s a bit difficult
there, we know, we all know the subject, we’ll start with
that, and then of course the
next ones  Steps are also taken by the
African countries as far as that is concerned,
then of course
I would also like to address many things. I would like to meet with
many children who have diabetes
and meet many parents and
just send the
message out there that everything
is possible and yeah  Let's see
what the next steps
will be like  lich with
tennis players and fathers often so
I somehow ended you
read that your own book
I read that yes the open crass book
it’s about father then in
Germany there is the whole Steffi Graf and
father story there are thousands of
examples why  it's so crass with
tennis players and
finding the relationship but you also have to
be able to distinguish between the real fathers
you can't throw everyone into one
pot so for me it's
really like that my father used to be a
tennis player that's the big
difference there understands that  Tennis life
understands that I had to be left
alone, understands how we
meet on the tennis court, but then
I don't want my peace for the next 22 hours
and that's completely okay for him,
with many
parent-child relationships it's just
different, they want it  Whole lives
they want to control then who you're friends with they want to control  en who you are in
a relationship with someone
control which dinner you go
to which partially control when
you go to sleep and so on and
so forth
for me that would be the case I would go
crazy well I am I am a
very
cheerful person as far as that goes
I also like to go to a restaurant I also like to be with my boyfriend from time to
time I also like
to have fun like that and he understands that
even without that I would you I would go
crazy
super tennis player in the end apparently
also one often at least one  have a close
relationship with their fathers and
these fathers can somehow bring them there
,
yes, I know, well, I don't know whether
that has anything to do with it now, so the
best tennis players like Federer Nadal
have nothing to do with their father and
then she has one now  Having an uncle
at Novak is also so that the family was
very close and then broke up a
bit, so
you have to have a certain mentality
you have to have a certain strength in
yourself and yes i don't know
so clearly my father helped me
that's not a question but i
don't know if that's
the most important point to become a professional
player that you with your
Father somehow had to travel for 30 years
so I, uh, you have right now
you somehow have to take part in life a little bit,
uh, nevertheless, I
have the feeling that when we somehow made
this appointment today,
you don't have to take special
care of you because then  was the question will you
come to our office here in Hamburg and
then
no no no no no so Alex doesn't leave the facility under any circumstances he
's on the facility he
doesn't even want to go out he just wants to
play tennis he wants to be here  somehow
just doesn't want to go into town
so i have so to be honest
i don't have that much time either so
i train i plan to i think the
training is done  I've
worked on my physio now I'll talk
to you and I'll go straight to the court if you're going to do that
. That means I've had to
prepare
for a tournament like that, especially when
I was out for four months
now not particularly the time
to do something else no that's that
's something else I would have loved
to come to your office
if it's somehow like that
I didn't mean it it was just so crass because I really have to be very disciplined  I want to prepare I want
to play here, that's the main thing for me,
so that means you're
going to celebrate somehow or something, if you
're in town
now, I don't do that now, so in general, are
there any favorite tournaments
that you go to because that  somehow has such a
great environment or
there is an environment doesn't mean that I
go partying the environment is just
I love Madrid, for example because I
I won there twice I played a final once
and I don't think the stadium
is cool so no so
winning first always helps
the atmosphere sometimes I love
Australia for example or
I've never won it but I just love being
there I love the
people  I love the surrounding atmosphere,
I love being in the city
, going out for dinner and so
on, I love Rome, e.g., um, but it's
really more like the stadiums, the
atmosphere is increasing, that makes a difference,
no, not
just the trappings, like I
said  in Australia
I think the surroundings are great so I think the city is great
I think
the people are great and I find everything
around it just really relaxed and
cool even if I'm to be that's why it
's not just the stadium
the stadium you like the stadium where you
win  this is quite simply which
the hardest for you tournament hardest
to win probably probably here
on  Lawn didn't
even read that it was all so
loud because there's so much action and
because there are always planes
I don't think so at all I think I find
Usedom e.g.
some of the most relaxed I think the hardest two are
scooters out because it's on the sand  is a
physical tournament
and Australia because it's 45 degrees there
, those are the two of them,
congratulations, those are the two hearts,
and last year Tokyo was awesome, so
Tokyo was in 40 degrees of heat,
100% humidity, we were all
dead, so
the other players  you
deal a lot with the opponents and that you
observe what they do who comes in as a
new player are you now closer in the US
Open when we speak the
US Open is still running the new the new players
the young players is
busy for you because this  they're just
new the others you know ne so the
the new the young
ones busy I think they've already
gotten to a lot with the Altaras  a lot of people have been busy with senses in the
last few months
but I think it has been for a
two years now so
everyone is dealing with the boys players and
are you a little worried because they
are so strong they didn't play two
days ago worry  Don't worry at the
end of the day nobody kills me
so they prevent
yes others have prevented
it at the moment I'll say so at the moment we still
have the novax and the Rafa prevented in the world
don't
don't believe in
general I hit the suckers last year
so of course they are great
players but for me
personally the other two have
prevented me a little bit so far what do we have to do in
Germany for tennis to come
back here because it doesn't feel like it's
anymore that's that's that's a
question I could ask you  now write a book
about it and be honest
but the top one wish from you
that the mentality remembers i  n
Germany yes tennis
to be honest about sport in general
you just need more athletes who are up for
it or no you need
more parents who are willing to
give something up for it okay because it's just so hard
also as
priorities ne so
the manities set the mentality for it  are
really committed to showing that you
want to play tennis, football is
different, the club takes care of football and
everything in tennis is not okay, that means
you need structure
that can produce stars at all,
you really need parents who
are willing to do something for it and still
I think that, like in Germany, we don't have that
much to be honest, in the end you
can almost say that the country is a
bit too full for the country, the country
is made for football, I would have been
okay if I could say it like that, but I think so
it would be I mean you've already
seen it works yes it's possible
so we have but it works bute  r first
saw how much did my parents give
up for it how much did my
parents do for that's
nice that's something different so that's not
something that many people do and want
to do thank you very much for your time thank you very much all right thank you ciao
[music  ]